doesn't end here bro i like where your
head's at that's how you
you live in the game bro i'm out of the
pro i'm out of practice
i said this nando's an asset that's done
bro
well all right all right all right um
guys welcome back welcome back welcome
back
um what's good good good before we get
the ball rolling
it's that time to give our ryder dive
patrons uh they're well deserved shout
outs
so let's see what we're booging with
this week we've got a newbie
cheeky newbie called makida nikita
makeda
jumped on here's your shout out we love
to see it we hope you're enjoying
yourself
uh benissa
welcome yeah we shower that she's been
about she's been about
um same as storm storm's still here we
love to see it
i actually like that name storm storms
calling it yeah it's dope
um aidan as always come on now
come on now aiden in the car um
yours your main man iok a cool yeah
yeah i butchered names today i did my
due diligence
um and then obviously the og ethan
my guy been about staying strong we love
to see it
same with callum about they're the true
ride or dies
ride or dies um and obviously yes we'd
love to see it so
guys we hope you're enjoying the stereo
conversations um
and yeah give us your feedback um
as well guys you know the drill jump on
that patreon
join your comrades yeah man for sure get
busy in the comments get busy
um with the likes and um we hope you
enjoy this
one get comfy it's going to be a doozy
let's jump in
um so this week's fun fact is in 1971
a high school student called julianne
kopke was
sucked out of an airplane after it was
struck by lightning
she fell three kilometers from the sky
still strapped to the chair
and then lived to then walk to then
endure
a 10-day walk to the nearest
civilization she was the only survivor
i'll give you more that was just like
the brief summary i've got like the full
thing so your face bro
every time i give you some of these
facts right i don't believe a word i
know i
don't believe a word of it that's why i
couldn't just leave it there i have to
give you the yeah yeah yeah
go on so i'm not going to read the whole
aeroplane name blah blah this commercial
airline was struck by lightning
during a severe thunderstorm and it
broke it broke into pieces in mid-air
disintegrated through and two miles
above the ground
so cop key still strapped onto her chair
survived the fall to earth suffering a
broken collar bone
a gash to her left leg her right arm and
her right eye was her right eye was
swollen shut
she said i was definitely strapped in
and she said
i was definitely strapped in when i fell
she later then said it must have turned
and buffered when i crashed because
otherwise she would have died she would
have survived
um her first priority was to find her
mother who was sat next to her
but then her search was unsuccessful she
later then found out her mother
initially survived the crash but died
later on due to injuries
she was surviving on sweets she found at
the site when she was when it was landed
and she wadded downstream through her
knee-high water as her father had taught
her tracking down system
eventually oh sorry as her father had
taught her tracking downstream should
eventually lead to civilization
which is very [ __ ] smart very after
10 days she found a boat
more near a small shelter she poured
gasoline from a fuel tank onto her
wounds
cleared them of maggots and spent the
night in a shelter she said i remained
there but
what i remained there but i wanted to
leave i didn't want to take the boat
because i didn't want to steal it
the next morning a small group of
fishermen discovered her and brought her
to the village
the following day a local pilot
volunteered to fly her to a hospital
in paco calpa i'll go where that is in a
second
where she reunited with her father after
recovering from her injuries
she was assisted she assisted search
parties in a in locating the crash site
and recovering the other bodies of the
victims her mother's body was found on
the 12th of january 1972 and the crash
happened in
19 for the 20th of december 1971
so it took them less than a month to
find her mom and where she
dropped was in peru so pacalpa
where she um sorted out injuries is in
peru
so that's where she landed well that's
where she's landed and they'll walk down
to
but it's a real story it's a real song
so
so hang on
her name is julian koepke
so let me get this straight so we're in
the plane yeah
just flying as normal lying at you
lightning bolt bang
sucks me and my chair out of the hole
and i'm
falling straight in strapped in three
kilometers
above ground above ground and i land on
the floor
but i'm alive yeah she happened i don't
i don't know how she
managed to be like if i'm this isn't
fact this this isn't false
it's a fact don't look at me like that
like i wrote the thing
it's like it's true stinks of foo hat
this stinks a fu head what does she even
knew
she dropped three kilometers in her
chair and just
survived the thing she had injuries
injuries galore then got infested with
maggots her arms no right um
her arm her leg her eye and her
collarbone [ __ ]
and she was just out here just picking
maggots off and pouring gasoline on it
gasoline bro that would have is that
disinfectant what is that
yeah yeah of course is it like that's it
of course i don't know
alcohol any form of alcohol is a
disinfectant fair player on a gash or
like when you want to sterilize
something use alcohol
you know yeah i didn't even know i
didn't even know alcohol was in gasoline
gasoline is like benzene like similar
similar circles
that would done the dance for you why do
you know that i don't know i just know
it
i don't i don't have the answer i just
know it fair play
wrong it's always these men that know
how to survive in it
it's never the dons that just like me
you'll never find a james survive that i
will die in the flight because
god knows as soon as i've made it out
there i'm dead anyway anyway yes
pointless should have dumped me up there
fam i'll be climbing up the mountain
against the stream
climbing
bro but what would you actually do
though like if you were
if you crashed you hit the ground blah
blah blah you looked you look you're
strapped in you're literally the only
one left you're in some jungle bro
and you think [ __ ] would you have rather
have died
definitely i think you only say that now
because you
i don't know i don't know if i would
rather have died because i i've said it
i love life way too much you do
obviously that is a
tough situation to be in is tough like
to be a lone survivor of a crash
a lone survivor of a crash oh it's not
like a crash in civilization
yeah i mean i would probably at first
through the adrenaline be motivated to
survive
of course give me how long was she there
for 10 days or so 10 days
i think she was streaming the walk
everything from crash to
i'm being finished two days in bro i'd
have been like i wish i [ __ ] died i'm
surviving on sweets
as soon as i saw the first maggot in
there i'll kill myself
i'm not dealing with that i promise you
now i'm not dealing with that
i'd assume as soon as there's a maggot
there i'll assume i've lost my arm
that's my immediate assumption so
dramatic something and if i've lost my
arm then i might as well lose my life
you're so dramatic sometimes maggots fam
i know how did it get in there
i don't know there's just flies laying
eggs in my wounds yeah when she sleeps
in it
when she's not moving obviously that's
the only way because i'm assuming she's
not walking about magazines dropping on
her
i mean there's she's got it she was when
she was sleeping for sure jesus christ
christ
yeah i would scream woke up to just max
just picking them off your gashes bro i
would scream
that's an affection energy to you that's
infection
that's why she poured gasoline olive all
over she must have danced in it
when you said she poured gasoline on it
i thought you said she was gonna set it
alive
but you know when people like seal their
[ __ ] shut with fire
yeah yeah i thought you were gonna say
she poured gasoline on it i just lit
that [ __ ] up
just closed it it reminds me of a
rick and morty pickle rick episode where
pickle rick is fighting
um i can see his face in my head the guy
that's locked up in a in a room
in the embassy yeah and you're both
injured and he's like
and he lit the whole thing yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah such a dope episode
yeah yeah yeah
bro random uh i saw the best rick and
morty impersonator on tick tock the
other day
the best i need to show you i need to
show you bro
the best impersonator of rick and morty
i thought he was the
the actual voice actor but then i
remembered wait like as i'm watching i'm
like wait i know he's not the voice out
because i know who the voice actor is
is to say the voice actor does rick and
morty doesn't he yeah yeah yeah and this
guy i found on tick tock does rick and
morty
because he does you know that trend
where they're like oh when your
girlfriend says or when this girl says
oh i'm so happy you're not into anime or
whatever
um anime guys like are so gay or like
whatever and then they go
and they just start speaking japanese
thing he does that for rick and morty
bro let me show you so i started seeing
this girl
and she was like i'm so glad you're not
one of those guys that's into cartoons
[Music]
yeah you know what am i you know like a
baby or something
jeez you know i'm too busy watching the
news or
you know like like war documentaries
the golf you know definitely not cartoon
nah bro he can do morty's spot on rick
spot on
and mr meeseeks spot on that is
too spot on perfect that's the best
impression of anything i've ever seen
perfect i've watched rick and morty and
studied it that's
too perfect spot on wow
wow whoever if you guys have never
watched rick and morty you're missing
out i'll get your
[ __ ] together show one netflix we
haven't seen rick and morty get
your [ __ ] together don't be one of them
being the ass i can't team like watch
the [ __ ] show oh
rick and morty is the best it's so dope
the best i love it i've seen it multiple
times they need to
they need to run me the seasons all the
time they need to they need to drop
season six but i don't think they will i
think they've stopped have they stopped
i don't know i don't really keep up to
date with like i should but i don't
really keep up to date with like
i know what you mean yeah like i do new
seasons and stuff like that i see it
um i've seen netflix does that thing in
it you know if you leave
neverland to go to the screensaver and
it will tell you new season coming soon
new season comes soon
castlevania has got a new season coming
soon can't [ __ ] wait i think yeah
ozark's got another season coming in
i know uh what else did i see on there
it's got another season coming
i can't remember there's an anime on
netflix called be the beginning
have you ever discussed it before i've
seen season one i never haven't seen
season two has come out i know it's
quite yeah i haven't started watching it
yet
um finding neverland season two's come
out
i don't think that's on netflix yet but
finally neverland not finding neverland
the promise neverland the promise
neverland season one is on netflix
season two's come out and control i
haven't watched it yet uh season one
bangs i need to watch that i've heard
it's good not watched
um i don't know what i can't remember
what else was coming out but there's
some good stuff coming out man i can't
wait
um demon slayer season two comes out
this year
i don't know when we're gonna be able to
see the movie bro i can't wait to see
that movie
i can't wait to see that same because is
it
is it in demon slayer that the movie is
the
in between season one and season two so
you have to watch the movie yeah the
movie is essential to the plot
yeah which i'm so gassed about i hate
when the movies are completely different
yeah that's dope
completely different um but yeah man
there's some good [ __ ] coming out um
let's do would you rather but yeah oh
gang yeah
i got lost into that bro lost into that
yeah would you rather hit me up
um of course we know
who bought you this podcast today the
one and only
yeah man grooming company reminds
like smashmate um
but yeah guys you already know where it
is now the perfect pack is 3.0
come on now they don't mess about you
know they don't miss about guys
it's just like it's different it's so
easy bro you trim you get that blend
you moisturize you deodorize you've got
the toiletries you've got the the silky
smoothie
it's not a normal package it's not
something you find every day it rolls on
and on and on and on
and by the end of it you're just vibrant
and you're thinking bro if i don't get
brains today then what's the point
what was the point of all this treatment
what the what was the point in all of
this
it's like when girls get waxed yeah when
girls think they're getting pipe
and they go get that wash wax and then
they don't get a pipe they're like what
was the point
i am baby soft soft baby soft skin is it
i'm baby soft skin right now and someone
could be eating that
and baby sauce suffered i'm just getting
uneaten vexed
that's how you guys will feel bro that's
how you guys will feel
um so those of you have jumped on
already let us know what you think of it
yeah um because i already know it's good
vibes
great vibes um yeah we can attest to
that we've used
oh 100 bro 100 great vibes um
you know random do you know what i
actually like about it you know the
trimmer
[Music]
when it runs out of battery it just
stops
it stops so it's got like a it never
diminishes
the the blade count you know what i mean
yeah yeah it never like slows down
yeah yeah i've had old clippers before
bro they slow down
and they're like and then it gets cool
like you get like
you pluck it it's not plugged into you
on that this one it stays on full rev
and when it's done it just cuts
they say it's either the best treatment
or nothing at all bro um so guys
obviously fruit is going to let you know
what you need to do yeah man
to enjoy this my guys to get 20 off and
free shipping please use code
sng at manscape.com that's 20 off
free shipping manscape.com make sure you
use the code sng
to unlock your confidence and always use
the right tools for the job
with manscapes bro you've heard it here
first thing you hear it here again next
week
you know how it is you know this you
know the score you know the driver okay
would you rather have the best
pipe game ever but you only ever last 10
minutes
or you've got like bang average d
but you lost size in terms of like just
in the yeah i guess whatever whatever
makes
her happy okay you'll just smack bang in
the middle of it okay okay okay um
you're probably below average okay but
you can last 45 minutes straight
so i've got the best d in the last 10
minutes yep
or i've got a below average below
average d
and you lost 45 minutes i'll probably go
for bestie
without i think that goes without saying
because if
if if i'm if i kind of get my words out
if she's saying i've got the best deed
then the time is irrelevant
the time scale is irrelevant bro and
plus
strong pipe for 10 minutes who will be
kidding here
that's ages that's a lifetime
let's all just be serious for a minute
that's true that's true because
if you're having like a 45 minute
endeavor
you're gonna go from like very hard to
like 80 percent
to about 70 percent to back up to 80 but
depending on the mood depending on what
you're doing
you're not going to be rock solid 100
for 45 minutes
that's i have a viagra or an issue yeah
yeah yeah
yeah so yeah oh hard pipe best pipe 10
minutes
that's a no-brainer bro she's coming
every
a good time four to six minutes of full
play before that
and then a solid 10 minutes bro
who were kidding she's gonna be like
that's a lifetime
oh she's gonna marry you on the spot oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah
10 minutes of strong strong strong is is
ages bro i don't care what anyone says
there's certainly so many women
yeah but some bro sometimes
the 45 minute ones i love them of course
he doesn't
i love it who doesn't because you're in
it to win it in it bro
and you think bro i think i've been here
for three days oh time just flies
oh yeah it does i've been in situations
even like currently i've been in
situations where i'm like
bro i'm sure we've been there for two
hours i'm sure we have
because it's just amazing the whole
experience is crazy bro
yeah it's live man i do love that easy
um crazy but yeah i think that's an open
and
open crowd easy bro give me that ten
minutes
ten minutes rock solid bro i'll give you
one i'll give you one minute change
nine minutes nine minutes wrong and you
can do what you i'll pull out you can do
what you want for a minute yeah
ah you were not yeah that's easy that's
easy man easy
that's easy um with that yeah
have um have you actually now got two
questions
not two questions i've got one thing and
another question someone sent us so
actually ethan sent this uh to us um
right or die ethan so you know how we
hate johnny's yes
there's a thing called a galactic cap
have you heard of it
no bro basically a galactic cap
is the equivalent of a johnny but it's
like
it's just like a sticker that you put on
your tool okay to cover the
tape yeah okay and it's got like a
little so it's a sticker
that basically it's a sticker that looks
like that
okay yeah yeah yeah so galactic cap yeah
sticker that you just put on there
and it's got like a little hole so it's
got a hole that you put over your hole
okay so when you bust it's kind of it
sounds a little gross but when you bust
um instead of all collecting in one
little bit here yeah the second hole
when you go through the hole
it kind of layers the entire thing oh
yeah that makes sense
so when you're not it just like fills up
the whole thing like that yeah yeah yeah
yeah
so it's just a sticker so it's
apparently supposed to feel way better
than a johnny because it's just a little
sticker that you stick over your hole
and it goes down like halfway down your
tall yeah
and then it's just that's it okay and
you can feel everything okay
um i don't know how i feel about it
though i'm just thinking about the
mechanics of it because how does it
how is the um what's the word i'm
looking for
how does it protect you like that can it
not fall off
things like you know what i mean because
if it's not it's a sticker it's like
it's got the
the adhesive on it okay that sticks to
your tool
the the adhesive that sticks to your
tool yeah so 60 or tall
and it um the it's like resistant to
like bodily fluids
okay so the wetness the wet wet does it
that won't do nothing to it it said
apparently so liver and wet wet won't do
nothing to it
but oils will so you can't use lube when
you're using it
okay oils so when you want to get it off
it says use baby oil
okay and you just rub baby on it and it
will just crimp up and come off okay
um i don't know i don't know how i feel
about that
i feel like
i feel like as a man it doesn't really
matter how i feel about it
i feel like it affects the woman more
because i don't think like they wouldn't
want that inside them
you know because it's like a foreign
body no one's i've never heard of that
it's not something that i'm assuming is
very popular oh yeah there's always
something i don't think they've even won
inside them so it's a pointless yeah
it's one of those weird ones the
johnnies are so whack
that you just you just take the l like
there's no like
i don't know i've never thought like oh
if any joiners were like this i'll wear
more it's just like i don't want
anything to do with you yeah i don't
want anything to do with them
we're gonna be using johnny's and i'm
gonna have a terrible time and i'm just
ready to deal with that
yeah yeah um but
yeah like i don't know i thought it was
interesting when i looked at it i was
like damn
i've never heard of that in my life um
galactic cap and is this for sale now or
is this like an apple type thing it's
out
open market i'll do some research on
that because i've never heard of that
before
yeah but the thing i wanted to ask you
yeah was
have you ever smashed a ting
that was so basic that even i don't know
about it
or maybe not me but like you don't tell
anyone about it
there are very few women
that i've had sex with that was just the
one time
you know and the ones that have been the
one time you already know about
so i uh i can safely say no
especially like if you're talking about
me telling you yeah you safely say no
you know because since i've known you
you you know about the things i've
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah girlfriends
i've had them blah blah blah is there
any that you've done that you think
i don't even want to tell anyone um yeah
for sure
not even necessarily tell anyone it
sounds so bad what i'm about to say
but it's one of them ones where i don't
want no one to know who she is
not necessarily tell anyone because i've
taught you like i said you've known all
the people i [ __ ] because
we ever gave them aliases but i just
don't really want no one to know who she
is
you know because it was one of them ones
where i could see her in my head right
now yeah
and it's just one of them once where
this was a while ago so just for fyi
like time frames this is a while ago
um it you know them ones where
you know you're not attracted to this
girl and it's
it's kind of like a step over thing like
a step over here kind of thing but it's
not one of them ones where i actually
ruined her life but yeah she was so
down that it turned me on you know
but only me and her to my knowledge only
me and her knew about this yeah yeah you
know yeah yeah no one else did yeah
you knew of the chick like not not of
the chick bite i have told you about the
chick before that bro i can't remember
what alias i gave her when i told you
but it just
wasn't someone i'd be like oh let me
show you instagram
it would it wouldn't be one of them once
you probably know what you did
you probably like it i feel like
as a man i feel like every man has kind
of been there in a situation like that
oh bro everyone's smashed a meaty thing
like a just a baseline
like a thing
my i definitely have
um in the sense that you [ __ ] the
thing and never told me or
i don't think i told you about it at the
time actually i didn't i didn't tell
anyone about it but i got found out
i think on the better episode i made
slight reference to this okay i didn't
give like the full story
okay so basically it was a ting um
in uni and she played for the uni
basketball team okay
and uh she was bro
she was so just like supper
yeah not hot yeah like i wasn't
attracted to her in the slightest
did she have attributes that make you
wanna nope this
okay the other one did okay she just
said
she had tea on the juiciest lips that
was it fair play that was it
fair play and i was like okay we have to
and
when we met we okay sorry to cut you off
with your story buff
i have to give you more context yeah i'm
so sorry i'm so sorry okay
so we met through tinder this is my
first stint on tinder yeah so this is
two years ago right yeah
we were talking talking talking and i
think obviously when you start to get to
the point of
what are you here for kind of thing
we're talking to that aspect and i asked
her
what are you here for something like
that and she said you oh
exactly you can't tell i don't care
sometimes i don't care what you like you
can't tell me those things
because i'm going to tingle i'm going to
tangle
you know i'm going to tingle and then
yeah
obviously it's different it's different
seeing people on
ins on instagram or twitter or tinder
rather
yeah than seeing them in real life yeah
of course and you can't
back down once she's at the yard you
know you have to go through
yeah when you
i wasn't sexually attracted to her yeah
as a as a woman
i was sexually attracted to the idea of
the sex with her
yeah that makes sense because like i
said she had very big tits
her lips were juicy and i just knew she
was down for me yeah
she was down yeah yeah yeah that turned
me on
yeah of course she wasn't banging yeah
just turned me on
yeah okay cool this is why we're [ __ ]
this is why we're [ __ ]
all right multiple times oh right cool
but yeah cool that was a long time ago
cool back to your story um basketball
oh yeah so basketball cough yeah really
didn't find her attractive
yeah yeah and she was down and i could
tell she was down
yeah so with talkers like friends but
then i will get little senses here and
there
that she was down and then i think yeah
i definitely told the story before but
basically she messaged me when she was
out and drunk said i want to come
through okay and
stuff and i was like and i was way too
shy and polite to say no
and then she came through and then it
was a whole
palava she thought she was so buff in
that moment and
i'm glad she did because empower
yourself in it you should think you're
buffing banging but i was just so
not honest what year was this was your
first year
no this was second year okay and i
didn't want
anyone to know yeah bro i didn't want
anyone to know so she must have snuck
out the flat in the morning
and i'm like cool so i stayed in my room
for like another 10-15 minutes
steps into the kitchen i see steve
um stephen sitting there eating a cereal
just staring at me
just staring at me and i was like oh
what's good g
and he's like oh what's up and he's just
smiling i
i played it thinking he don't know he
don't know he don't know because my door
was like
two steps from the front door you come
out of my bedroom flat door's there yeah
yeah
get the [ __ ] out yeah so she would bang
out
um obviously i didn't see her leave i
just like she went with them and i heard
the door like cool
he's smirking family stared at me and
then um
he's like uh he looks up and i was like
cool and i'm just sorting myself out
and i'm like ah how's your morning going
and stuff like good good good this is
enough
staring at me and i'm like cool cool
cool i'm still thinking he don't know
yeah yeah he don't know
he don't know and then man's like bro
check this i'm gonna have to bait the
girl's name because i don't want to ruin
the story just by not saying a name yeah
so um he's sitting there eating a cereal
staring at me
emma's like oh um
yeah okay um so yeah i was um
yeah yeah so man's like oh i just saw
let's call
kate um he's like oh i just saw
kate leave and i was like
i froze my i was in the fridge and i
wasn't looking at him i froze
just standing in the fridge and i was
like oh was
and it was like yeah yeah yeah leave
still and i was like
oh okay what are you telling me for
that that's cool yeah good for you and
the man's like
hey and i was like what he's like i
heard violins
slow violence it was like hey and i was
like
i put the fridge down there to look and
i was like what's up and he's like
we've all been there i'm not sorry what
i wanted to like cry you know you just
want to cry violence i'm like
what what
man said bro we've all we've all been
there desperate times call for desperate
measures bro we've all been there
and
i was like bro i didn't even want to
he's like i know but he might sort of
just hug me
bro i know i know you didn't want to
he said neither did i oh i said never to
die and i was like and did she do that
he's like yeah yeah
that's too funny bro i've never bonded
with someone
like that i never bonded with someone oh
i wanted to cry
i felt so low okay here's a question
yeah yeah
do you think a girl has ever done that
to you
oh um
that's a very good question that's a
very good question
i wonder if a girls have done that to me
i wonder if the girls have done that too
i'm trying to think of every guy i've
ever said but to think
if that probably was the case
i don't think so
i don't think so i think the only reason
i would say is because i've never
slept with someone who i've never slept
with someone who
i'm known within that friendship group
to the point where they just don't want
people knowing that they were dealing
with me
i think the only time would probably be
people who
have slept with me previously have
washed their hands of me
and have then come calling back yeah
okay and then
probably had to have been like yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and everything's been like no why i know
what you mean
i say that the one time that i probably
happened was that time
with the the time where me and you were
watching tv
and then i had a random nude from
someone i'd slept with yeah before
hadn't spoke to him in months random
knew she was like come through now yeah
out of nowhere and at the end of it she
she just wanted me to like it was all
obvious that she just want me to stay
the night yeah
and i was just like nah yeah like nah
and i felt so bad cause i was just like
oh this is really sad now
you didn't even want me for the sex yeah
you didn't even want you just wanted
company if you just want company you
should have said but you were
so certain that i would never just come
around to spend time with you
that you have to put palm on the table
bro
heart-wrenching heart-wrenching
obviously it wasn't enough to make me
stay but heart-wrenching nevertheless
i still got on with my evening
still got on my even the same way came
back in time to i think we were watching
um
homeland were we i think we were
watching homeland what a show
i think we're watching homeland and i
remember thinking i want to get back to
finish this episode
it was a quick nipping nip out and i
remember i was driving that year
quick bang bang in and out going i made
it back like
i just sat down like where were we
on some tea voting
that's joking yeah bro that was a good
one but yeah i could tell she was so
lonely man blessed
are you not going to stay the night and
i was like hell no no hell no
bless come on man um but yeah that was
heart-wrenching
that was heart-wrenching that's probably
one of the only ones where maybe i'm
thinking like
they might have yeah like she probably
would have told her friends about that
the next day and their friends were like
what's wrong
why would you do that and they're like
oh i don't know i was feeling lonely
so yeah i think there's a couple times
where people have lonely banged me
well we've we've had stuff before in the
past and then they've just got in
contact
because they're just one company
which is depressing um but i don't think
there's ever been a time where
someone's like no one can know that i'm
about this guy
yeah no one can yeah i don't think
that's ever happened but do you know who
i think that's happened to a million
times
who um a guy from our uni
i don't want to bet his name a guy from
our uni light-skinned breda
saucy and
[Music]
exactly you're talking about i reckon
he's had that happen to him about 9 000
times
about 9 000 times ah because he was such
a monolithic [ __ ] yeah and he wasn't
even
that buff yeah so you know the girls
just got drunk and they thought
they're just like oh why yeah infamous
[ __ ] on campus
he was because everyone knew he was
[ __ ] he was just down to the
boundaries
yeah yeah he was down to buying anyone
so if you got caught in that web
uh part of his collection you're part of
the collection you need to make sure he
keeps his mouth shut and he never did
he never did he told everyone everything
oh yeah yeah yeah that's
100 percent he's had that happen to him
so many times
that's joe's so amazing do you think
that's ever happened to you i don't
think
i think what's happened to me is a
similar what's happened to you in a
sense that
i've [ __ ] a trick in the past
it's dwindled out and it's kind of
recycled and revived itself
um i've got a few in my head obviously i
don't want to say their names or aliases
because i'm pretty sure quite a few of
them watch this okay
um but you know you know corpse yeah
yeah yeah yeah you know exactly that
yeah yeah yeah she doesn't know but you
know
yeah yeah yeah yeah um so her we
obviously we used the [ __ ] you know used
the [ __ ]
um in the past uh it was only for like a
small stint
and nothing else happened of it stopped
both moved on with our life and i
thought i think yeah year and a half
later
we were somewhat but it took
it was one of those ones where because
she knew
the sex we used to have was great
that she had no she had no real leg to
stand on when we when she was single
again
because she obviously stopped talking
not necessarily stopped talking to me
but still stopped talking to me in that
way yeah when she had a man
yeah understandable yeah and i wasn't
mad at whether it just wasn't what yeah
yeah yeah
but i knew i knew when she was ready to
come back
and it was like it's gang but it's like
were you just waiting to be single yeah
like do you
i don't know how to explain it but it
was it's it's similar to what you said
anyway like i've i've had
the recycling thing but i don't think it
sounds sorry that sounds like um
where like say like she's and that one
sounds like she's got this
like spiderweb ridden
dusty old black book kept in a draw
somewhere
and then she's living her relationship
life yeah and when that ends
she's like and then just pull the edge
pause it out and just
boom just flicking through looking
through him like
cool yeah he's been holding me quite a
bit yeah
i know he was down that pipe was good
all right here we go here we go
and then and then you see [ __ ] for a
bit again and then cooperating
yeah yeah but yeah um the reason why i
don't think it's happened to me
because nine times out of ten
when i do away games i'm dipping anyway
yeah yeah yeah
and if they come to me it's never going
to be a case of they're not trying to be
seen [ __ ] me because nine times out
of ten as well they dip as well and it's
like yeah yeah you know it's one of them
i don't think that's ever happened to me
before but
again i could be wrong you know i could
be oh yeah i could go wrong but
i don't know i don't really yeah i think
yeah it's it's more likely to happen in
occasions where
you're you're in a not a circle but you
know people know
who you are and who they are and stuff
like that yeah so like potentially if
you were to sleep with someone from your
work
it could be a case of like both of you
like this can't get out yeah yeah you
just can't get out yeah like you need to
keep your mouth shut
for me i don't know anyone yeah um so
yeah that would never happen well it
could happen but still i think it's more
unlikely to happen but
oh that time the stevie kitchen time
it happens to all of us fam he's like
we've all been there before
i didn't like it man said he was looking
in the fridge just like what's that
just staring at the cheese i didn't know
what to do or say
i was so embarrassed that's jokes bro um
but yeah let's do um
thinking the jiggy what oh let's do uh
one's gotta go
oh yeah sure forgot about that this
week's one's gotta go
is just based on random [ __ ] i've got a
segment for just random [ __ ]
so we'll do that one now um
one's gotta go birds yeah the animal
yeah roaches spiders okay
and moths oh wow
i want them all gone i know you do
birds roaches
spiders spiders are moths bro
moths are they're not even terrifying
they're just annoyingly
disgusting i hate moths with
every fiber of my being they can do
nothing to me bro
oh i just oh when they when they get up
in here and then you feel it it hit you
and you're like oh that's heavy
it's just it's got weight on it feel
like i'm infected if they touch you yeah
same
infecting i hate it so much
um oh man i think it's i hate spiders
but in comparison to all of those things
i love spiders in comparison to all of
that roaches bro
yeah oh the whole world knows how i feel
about them one of the funniest stories
you said on this bud
oh my god um
right birds
i'm thinking boy i don't know why i'm
thinking like this is gospel like say if
i just say
birds i can rid the world
like it's set in stone that's hilarious
i think immediately i jump to roaches
because they're just the worst creatures
imaginable
but then again i've seen a roach once in
my life and hopefully i won't ever see
another one
so it's one of them was like is it even
worth it yeah when i can get those birds
out of here
i hear those birds out of here for good
they're gonna be there tomorrow bro
bro i know i'm gonna okay if you're on a
completely neutral plane
that has nothing to do with how often i
have to interact with these creatures
based on pure disgust roaches have to go
okay
oh they're the worst all right
one's gotta go your dream house your
dream job
your dream car or your dream
relationship
so i'm not having one of these you're
not having one of these
my dream job dream house dream car
dream relationship
dream car can go i love um
to be honest i'm not entirely sure which
is probably why i can go
i'm not entirely sure um
i don't know to be fair what would my
dream car be
i don't know because it's weird because
because obviously everyone knows i want
to get my dad that aston martin
it makes me romanticize the aston martin
which makes me think that i want the
aston martin
which i definitely do because i [ __ ]
love us to mines but is it your dream is
it
actually my dream car yeah yeah yeah or
am i have i just obsessed about it so
long because i want to get it for dad
um i really don't know to be honest with
you dude
i really don't know and i go off cars so
much because i love cars
when i get into a car i research the
[ __ ] out of it
and then by the time i'm done like i'm
done
i've seen it for all its flaws and i'm
like [ __ ] that car like i don't want
that car
um but yeah my dream car ever
maybe like and
i think at the minute just for the sake
of the [ __ ] you money
would be like a lamborghini urus
the 4x4 one funny you said that because
i was thinking
mine would be the four by four rolls
royce
oh okay i like they just look powerful
yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] powerful yeah yeah yeah sbc yeah
man i think i would get the urus
and you just see i saw a bright orange
one the other day and i was like
this guy's got money fam yeah
money money i've seen i've seen a video
maybe you sent me i can't remember um
it was a lamborghini a bright orange
lamborghini
um in like a ditched dirt and
lamborghini europe jumped over it yeah
[ __ ]
might probably yeah i saw that somewhere
yeah bro [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] i think i saw a meme
about the other day and was i wish i had
i wish i was this rich and bored i think
you did send it because i think that was
the capital oh right
bro outrageous
yeah man i think at the minute if i had
a yours that's just that's just the
pinnacle of like
i've got cake and there's nothing anyone
can say to deny it
fair enough do you know what i mean this
is certifiable i think the cheapest one
you can get is like 200k
really used cheap ting oh wow 200k
money mom money bro money so yeah
dream car can go but yeah i'd love to
have a euros
cool all right okay next one's gotta go
toothpaste deodorant shower
gel body cream good one
body cream why
because as much as
cream in my body is essential and more
the these things i more think about
actually to be fair
toothpaste is for me toothpaste is for
you so okay
so me wearing deodorant i'm more
concerned about how offensive my smart
is to anyone
else me using shower gel
again is probably more for me because i
feel clean once i've used that so shower
gel and toothpaste are for me
because they're i feel clean with those
cream and deodorant are for everyone
else
cream's kind of for me because you want
to feel soft but i've gotten
i've gone days about using cream before
just when i haven't had it
and obviously your fingers get ashy and
your knees get ashy and stuff like that
just to go
suck that suck that webbing yeah
but i did once you're back to square one
yeah
it's all good but i'm just fisting
scissors
on the knees yeah you're good to go yeah
yeah yeah um but yeah i think
cream can go okay because i think i'll
survive without it
but with everything else now no way okay
i could never survive our deodorant
never in a million years fair enough all
right one's gotta go
your phone your car hot showers
or a hot meal oh my god good question
dude
my phone my car
hot meals or hot showers hot showers
ain't going anywhere
i'll tell you that now out of all of
that
the thought of losing hot showers for
life i
i'd happily commit suicide
i would ah that's not a thing that's not
a thing
hot meals i'd like to oh bro nah
cold meals are [ __ ]
[ __ ] but no car no phone
i need them both drive more than you
walk
yeah that's the thing i drive everywhere
so i need my car
i'll probably get rid of my phone why
only because of the lineup yeah only
that one's purely based
on everything else and there's probably
some
relief in not having a phone at some
point yeah yeah once you get past the
original panic
yeah and the fomo yeah you'd
reach this point of serenity yeah and
you're like oh i'm fully like detached
yeah from the toxic addiction i have
with my phone like i can actually
look up and see [ __ ] now yeah so
there'll be a bet there would be a
benefit at the end of the tunnel for the
phone thing
but the first cold going cold turkey
would be a nightmare yeah
it would be a nightmare but i need my
phone yeah you'd be like an addict
hey what's up big man show me your phone
let me see
let me see what food you got yeah yeah
jesus christ
see ya phone can go oh yeah that's a
good answer
all right last but not least funky house
r b yeah hip hop slash rap
okay slow jams
i'd say funky house can go okay why only
because i haven't had it in like a
decade already
it's basically gone but when i do hear
it now euphoria you're in it
it's the throat of me so far back i
thought you thought
that's what i'm looking for reminiscent
do you know what reminds me of you know
do you remember when um
this is why i hate people bro
people in clubs are losers myself
included okay
do you remember back in the funky days
um
that song that um i don't wanna i don't
wanna be with you go
go home
[Music]
when that song came on was so aggressive
really i'd get fingers in my face from
strangers
from strange i'm just trying to dance
they get so embarrassed
if you make eye contact with pretty much
doing that go
home pacquiao okay
step back
[Music]
then we come back in oh and she's like i
don't want to be
if you get that nah
nah they were aggressive i suppose i
don't even know you
stop fearing the song oh bro uni days
funky
so sick so sick um i was thinking about
that because
randomly i started listening to um
like old school jasmine sullivan the
other day okay just ran it in the shower
i just ran and listened to it
and one funky dub track bro the funky
mix that she used to have was that um
i broke a windows at your cupboard
bro the funky version of that was so
sick
i remember i threw me back because i
heard the original i was just like
oh yes bro um
yeah it's but yeah it pains me to say
funky can go
funky's i've lived it mm-hmm they have a
little it's not coming back it was a
great time
it was a great time guys in the comments
if you guys lived or loved funky back in
the day yeah if you're old enough to
remember funky house showers let us know
what your best or favorite funky tracks
were in the comments
car it would give us time to reminisce
as well it was bro
funky house era was unmatched when it
came up when it came on in the raves
everyone's going mad
[Music]
went off
[Music]
oh yeah all right cool let me do it uh
for them
ah that was a good one i like that one
cool
um
right okay so this one is more of a fan
request than marty [ __ ]
uh well it's way more but he needs help
now oh okay better so
so this is what i do we're still i've
left him hanging a few weeks so i'm
sorry
um but let's see if we can help you out
now so man said howdy lads
uh from australia and i need help
well you mentioned whether you answer
this on the party or not i just need
help
i've seen that bit i don't think i've
read the whole thing all right cool so
man said quick context
she's kept postponing the first date
because she's got work
but finally this sunday night we're set
to get
a cheeky nandos um i think i've read
this bro
man said what the [ __ ] should i wear
yeah yeah i've read this
all right because this one's a bit
different i said honestly my wardrobe is
filled with nightclub and clothes
and i'm not [ __ ] this up i've been
there being a sweating
i know this girl so banging to him to
him yeah to him
so banging him you can tell he's like 18
19. yeah probably
brown man said i know this seems like
i'm a younger but i'm not i'm 19.
big man you're younger you're younger
[ __ ] you young
shut up you've been young
um man i said but i've been out the game
for a minute now
and i've been subbed back in um
bro tag me in coach i'm ready
so um yeah what the [ __ ] should he wear
well he said he's got all his stuff for
night clubbing stuff nightclub and
clothes
but i mean i feel like definition of
nightclub and close down
one two and i feel like it's a hard
question to ask us
purely because what are you asking us
should you buy new gums
and what should you wear are you giving
us options are you showing us what your
wardrobe looks like can we pick it out
for you
okay do you know what i mean okay cool
let's set the premise then
all we know is that it's 19 so i'm
assuming she's around the same age
and they're grabbing the cheeky nandos
so that's like a smart casual yeah
more probably more casual more casual
than smart for sure
cool so you want to go more casual but
he wants almost to
make an impression yeah so you want to
be like a buff casual
you live in australia it's hot as [ __ ]
over there but then again
i don't know if it's cold right now over
there sometimes it gets cold well i'm
sure it gets cold then when it gets hot
here
i'm assuming so so i'm assuming yeah i'm
assuming that summer is like december
february
yeah if it were me okay say what you'd
say i'm gonna say what i'd say and then
you can say what you say okay
so my head i'm thinking
this would be for me like white kicks
always look clean white kicks with like
blue jeans and this is a black don so
maybe like a buff
salmon sweatshirt or something
just let your skin do the talking yeah
boys let the glow do the talking
boys nice watch obviously bro and i
think your i think you're set
minimalist and just you're just ready
you're here okay
i like that you look like you just
showered i like that
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah salmon top
to match the lips
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah she's just
gonna be staring at that
you've got a bit of sun let me stop that
what i would wear i would probably still
go for white kicks as well
but i'll probably go from would i go for
black jeans
no let me start from the top i would
wear
smart cash i think i'd wear a shirt you
know really
depend like eight nine eighteen nineteen
i'm trying to press a go i'm thinking
about wide web i'm thinking about
his mindset okay makes sense yeah yeah
so i'm 18 19.
nando's yes is a casual casual casual
spot but you obviously like this girl
for a minute it's a first date you want
to impress it
go i'm wearing i'm wearing a shirt a
loose
shirt i knew you were going to say that
a loose baggy shirt button out and down
to e out not not too much tea but you
can see the teeth
[Applause]
so she can see what i'm kind of working
with yeah and i'm a bit flaccid but i'm
there
you can see me you know what i mean a
bit loose obviously you've got the watch
on
you've got the ring on just a bit of
jewelry just to let her know that you
can provide take price
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'd probably go oh here's
wide well i'd probably go for
my um black and white loose tea my shirt
my black and white lucha button down
black jeans yeah with the white crepes
all right cool that's what i would wear
that means yeah yeah
you're there with the i'm here for a
good time not a long time
i'm no i'm awesome no no no i'm here for
a good time
not necessarily a long time but i'm also
here for a potential post nando's
yeah you know so i'm dressed for a
presumptual
bro i'm assuming i'm gonna say ain't
ending here it's not ending that none of
the bars are open
the birds are chirping let's see where
this chicken takes us
there we go that's why i like where your
heads at i like
yeah man said it doesn't end it doesn't
end here bro i like
where your heads at that's how you you
live in the game bro
i'm out of the out of practice i said
this nando's an asset that's done
bro bro nah you said nando's is just the
warm-up
i'm ready for anything let's get some
drinks off the bee
yeah you're ready for the cake yeah
ready yes flakes it makes perfect sense
you've only got
night clothes like going out close yeah
yeah yeah so we're the least
most going out close that to you
wear that to nando's and be like boom
babes it's eight o'clock
let's hit a bar you're now smart casual
for the bar
wow and she's obviously gonna look nice
regardless she's gonna be looking
banging regardless she's gonna look nice
yeah probably gonna be wearing some
pencil skirt
yeah some heels maybe some flats or
something open toe
nice little blouse she's going to be
ready for whatever anyway
yes she's going to be looking banging
her legs are going to be out you already
know it waxed
waxed glistening glistening
soft yeah she's ready for a good night
yeah yeah yeah you nailed it you know
that you know they listen to phrases
yeah yeah
let's sign off on that one bro enjoy
that enjoy that date
see you next week